your sword is on the beach by the way
there just saved you some time pretty
sure someone in that town someone who
leads to it it tells you about it but I
missed it so saved you some time Legend
of Zelda a link to the not a Link to the
Past zelda links awakening for the
switch is a remake of the old gameboy
game i never played it because they
didn't have a gameboy because I mean
this was Sega versus Nintendo one had to
choose and I chose you chose one eat my
nuts night it was a good system battery
life though who wouldnt is I never got
to play Link's Awakening before on the
Gameboy so now I get to play Link's
Awakening for the switch as the remake
and Link's awakenings awesome actually
kind of makes me pissed that I never
played it before on the Gameboy I feel
like I missed out it is an old-school
top-down Legend of Zelda game with
everything in there one would expect
from a top view Legend of Zelda game
first of all the switch graphics are
great everyone looks like a little
porcelain figures they even have this
really deep depth of field that makes
everyone look small I really enjoyed
that I enjoyed the aesthetic I enjoyed
the graphics most of all I enjoyed the
gameplay because yeah they crammed a lot
of stuff into this game I love the fact
that you have two buttons you can put
items in so you can have two items
equipped at the same time essentially
here's how it's gonna work out you're
gonna have the feather always equipped
cuz you always want your jump in there
the button can be whatever you want a
couple times early game I was kind of
lost so you know that YouTube was just
doing because like I said it's
old-school Zelda it's not always it
doesn't always point you in the direct
path there's these little phone booths
in trees and you pick up the phone you
get a tip kind of aiming you in the
direction sometimes they're Vegas [ __ ]
though anyhow point is when searching
for a couple of keys to get into the
dungeons went on YouTube but the game
had been out for like six hours so there
wasn't a lot of switch gameplay so I
just looked at Game Boy gameplay and it
was very applicable to the switch we're
talking dungeon construction creatures
spits it just makes the gameboy version
all that more impressive but I will say
now I have to say this now that I said
the first part to my shame I went on
YouTube after that I was like alright
I'm not gonna do that anymore that's the
part of Zelda is you got to figure it
out you got to be in
world just adventure and figure it out
and if you do that this is a Zelda
experience the likes of which your
parents only talked about you know what
I mean there's something very specific
about that we're it's like go adventure
you might be there for a day trying to
figure out this thing and once you
you've pushed every block and you've
used every item and finally you'll
figure it out like there's this one
dungeon with a big it was it's a big
stupid iron ball that you have to carry
around I was like what's this thing for
and I accidentally figured out because I
just accidentally did a thing at the
right time it just it was accident I
accidentally stumbled across the answer
that's so Zelda there's no other way to
say that so if you can resist going
online looking for tips makes it all the
more worth it this game is great it's
like a link between worlds I actually
heard this was going to come out for the
3ds after a link between worlds and they
kind of pushed everything to the switch
and they're like it's gonna come out for
the switch now but a link between worlds
and now Link's Awakening I chose me why
I love zelda 1 and a Link to the Past so
much cuz they'll the one in a Link to
the Past
I have played countless times even till
recently I just recently played Zelda I
recently played a Link to the Past for
the switch because you could play the
Super Nintendo games on the switch now
if you have the online service recently
maxed it out 100% because I know that
game inside out and backwards but this
is like that feeling of a Link to the
Past with me not actually knowing
anything even with a link between worlds
is the same general basic construction
of a Link to the Past so if you know a
Link to the Past you kind of know a link
between worlds to an extent a large
extent but this completely new overhead
old-school Zelda game for me and those
are my favorites because I love the 3d
Zelda games but as much as I love them
after I play them and while I'm playing
them during Norma they're so enormous I
don't go back to them Twilight Princess
Skyward Sword I played those ones I love
them but played them once wrath of the
wild I did play twice like back-to-back
played it beat it played it beat it but
Zell the one on a Link to the Past I've
played so many times and this is a game
on par with that like now that I've
beaten it there's enough endgame stuff
to do it doesn't have to be in game you
got to find these little seashells and
heart container pieces I'm missing three
heart containers which is twelve heart
container pieces which is kind of
baffling to me because I feel like I've
explored everything but obviously I
haven't so I've got to go back and do
that and I
to go back and do that after I go back
and do that I'll play through this game
again it took me two days to beat it's
not a long game when I say old-school
Zelda I mean but long game doesn't
necessarily mean great game or
vice-versa like a games enjoyment isn't
necessarily linked to how long it is I
mean you want your money's worth sure
but I can think of plenty of long games
that are just that there's it they're
long games some games are too short you
feel like you overpaid but Link's
Awakening I don't feel that way I feel
completely fulfilled I got my Zelda fix
whether you're a fan of the gameboy game
and you're returning to the world and
some nostalgia bomb you know for the
remake or it's your first time playing
Link's Awakening on any platform
whatsoever you're gonna have fun with
this I mean if you're a zelda fan
you don't like Zelda games you might not
it has a Zelda fan I'm smiling because
legend of zelda links awakening is
awesome tacular
all right so legend of zelda links
awakening to remake for the switch have
you played it what did you think about
it or have you played the original and
gameboy what did you think of that how
do they compare whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]